hey youtubers is Charlie and supposedly
a whole bunch of details about the first
20 minutes of Avengers age of Ultron
leaked and Mark Ruffalo has been teasing
a Hulk standalone movie because the
Avenger stuff doesn't really cover any
super critical parts of the story I
don't consider it super spoilery but
I'll still post a special warning and
hello to all the new people who are just
finding me for the first time I do
Marvel bonus videos every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I try to rotate the movies I do but
because guardians is coming up that's
plug in of me next week so what's going
on in the world of The Avengers well a
bunch of people got invited to this said
there's still about halfway through
filming but they got invited to England
in the place where they film all the
scenes in The Avengers Tower as well as
the Quinjet so they basically got to see
like where Thor sleeps and they got to
see the quintet yes there is a quintet
in the movie so I'm really excited so
the reason a bunch of story details
leaked is supposedly that group of
people got to see the first 20 minutes
of the movie because of that all this
seems a little bit more plausible so
careful for spoilers if you don't want
to know anything about Avengers 2 just
in case these things are actually in the
movie the movie is supposed to start
directly after that Baron von Strucker
scene in Winter Soldier the Avengers are
in the process of cleaning up the
remnants of Hydra just like Nick Fury
was talking about in the opening scene
they're conducting a hit on the lab that
Baron von Strucker is in it's a big
opening action set piece lots of
explosions
remember how Thor the dark world opened
on that Battle of Anaheim they're
basically opening the movie the same way
just a really big battle Baron von
Strucker is a lot like Hannibal Chau
from Pacific Rim remember Ron Perlman's
character he'd run in and steal bits of
the kaiju for experiments and shady
stuff von Strucker has the corpse of one
of the hour leviathans from the
Battle of New York along with a bunch of
shoot our weaponry and Loki's staff
which is supposedly powered by the my
gym so the Avengers are basically
running cleanup and that's when they run
into Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver who
are basically working with von Strucker
that opening battle ends up being a
really good intro to their characters
and showing off their shiny new powers
we haven't really seen their type of
powers in the Marvel Universe yet so the
funny part is is the Scarlet Witch
supposedly confounds the Hulk using her
magic like messes with his mind
she basically causes him to freak out
and smash the hell out of everything
eventually The Avengers do win and they
take Loki's staff and everything back to
the Avengers tower so then it breaks
into like a post win celebration like
they just won the World Cup
something but how did the Avengers party
whenever they win a big battle by taking
turns trying to pick up Thor's hammer
supposedly Tony Stark tries whenever
he's wearing his new armor he's got a
new version of the armor in this movie
of course whenever he lays into it his
arm on the suit just rips right out of
its socket but Captain America is able
to make it budge just a little bit in
case you've never read the comics
Captain America is actually able to pick
up Thor's hammer they haven't done it in
the movies yet so Avengers 2 might be
the first time we get to see that happen
also in the comics because Captain
America has the most noble heart he's
the one the Illuminati allowed to wear
the Infinity Gauntlet
whenever it contains all six gems he's
like the one person who wouldn't go mad
with power so if he's good enough to
wear the Infinity Gauntlet and control
all of reality then of course he'll be
able to pick up Thor's hammer later we
find out that supposedly Bruce Banner
and Black Widow have a thing going on
the side but because banner is afraid of
turning into the Hulk while they're
having sex
they haven't consummated the
relationship like they haven't done it
yet if you are a big Joss Whedon fan
from the 90s and you watched Buffy it be
a lot like Buffy's relationship with
angel speaking of ships if you did not
like Natalie Portman and Thor the dark
world
she and Thor are supposedly not together
anymore so she's not really going to be
in the movie other than like a really
small cameo so what did we learn about
the movie based on the screening well
basically after a Winter Soldier the
Avengers are just gonna start running
toxic waste disposal on all the remnants
of Hydra especially while guardians of
the galaxy is going on that's happening
between Winter Soldier and Avengers 2 so
it's all happening in real time
for example the events during Winter
Soldier are happening before the events
during guardians of the galaxy and the
events during ant-man will happen after
Avengers 2
so all these movies happen sequentially
and chronologically but based on this
new information let me know in the
comments what are you most excited to
see we don't have a ton of Ultron
details yet other than his general
origins being you know militarized start
tech personally I'm really looking
forward to seeing Scarlet Witch confound
the Hulk and just make him go crazy on
everyone and seeing Captain America pick
up Thor's hammer it's possible that that
scene of the Hulk fighting Iron Man and
his Hulkbuster armor was from that
Scarlet Witch scene the Hulkbuster stuff
was shot in south america so that sounds
kind of like where Baron von strucker's
lab was going to be
as for all their shipping stuff I don't
know how I feel about Avengers hooking
up with each other especially when the
squad is so small I'd understand a
little bit more if they were like 20
Avengers but we're not quite there yet
this is a Joss Whedon project though so
if you've ever seen something of his
then you know the minute a bunch of
crazy people get together to them are
gonna start having sex it just so
happens that in this movie the crazy
people are Earth's last defenders so
doesn't that just sound like high school
more from Mark Ruffalo in the hope
though he's been doing a lot of
interviews lately
and teasing a standalone cult film
Marvel's probably been quietly
developing one ever since they cast them
especially since after the Avengers did
so well but they have like a billion
other films that they want to release
first Avengers 2 though is supposed to
put the whole front and center like his
character is gonna be a core part of the
plot in the movie that doesn't mean
it'll be all hard but it'll be the
closest thing we'll get to a Hulk movie
until at least phase 3 or phase 4 in
terms of live-action stories I'd really
like to see them do Planet Hulk they've
done an animated version of it or world
war I feel like either one of those
would totally work so because guardians
of the galaxy is almost here in less
than a month I'm gonna be doing bonus
videos for that starting next week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
also just posted details on the new
comic book characters coming to arrow
season 3 including the Blue Beetle so
I'm really excited about that you can
click here to learn about it and click
here to learn all about Thanos's role in
guardians of the galaxy thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives